you're in a relationship now yeah well
uh I'm dating someone okay
I mean how is he gonna feel I'm
imagining he's gonna see this I don't
well you know what if he sees this
interview he may think you're in a
relationship and then you're on TV
saying I'm not in a relationship yet
like I thought we were and then when we
talked about it he he I don't we didn't
get clarity I don't know what it is why
didn't you do your mind control thing on
him should we weren't coz I mean we can
either widdle a baby and then he's like
we're in a relationship because I want
it to be genuine I said you know what
let's just be happy that won't work
ladies
say let's just be happy yeah let's just
be happy I'm happy with you exclusively
and you're happy with me exclusively
because you don't want him planting
everywhere and that's like genetically
and a man's look DNA you bet it is
I'm always out there planting know your
desire to play huh it's to keep the
population going yes what a plan exactly
but you won't because you have not know
you know you have you've made wasn't it
you've made a commitment I made a
commitment yes I am married yes I have
married yes and you have the children
which are the glue to the planting yeah
okay don't surrounded by snitches yeah
well now you're getting an iPhone yeah
so now you're planted yeah I am yes that
is true but what I'm curious about is
you say that you're not sure you're in a
relationship what what is it you need to
know that what what qualities do you
need to know this is real this is this
is the long haul what if it is it enough
that he's just a nice guy it might be
enough for like me but not her and we've
got to agree I sometimes I'm like I
think he's wonderful and she's like I
don't think so and then if we're not
speech she speaks to me that's not how
she sounds
[Laughter]
that is how she's found she's actually
aggressive no but it's like how a man is
you know how a man this says don't do it
and it says yes we're the reverse right
so we will go IRA gosh that's not how my
penis talks at all now she just says
she's closed so the mind and the body
must be together the relationship I have
to like him emotionally mentally and
physically so that we can get to that
next level get to that level yeah you
can't do it if you're you don't have a
vagina you don't know if you had a
vagina then you too would have known the
voice yeah okay
all right and you either yeah no I know
I
you had a vagina I did
then one trip to Copenhagen this is the
weirdest interview ever I love it I
absolutely love it
you